تسجيل اشتباكات متقطعة ليقول
وزير الخارجية الامريكي انه اذا
الشعب الروسي الذي وجد نفسه بسبب
الظلم التاريخي خارج حدود وطنه
الحرب لكنها تحاول بمساعدة مكتب
العمليات الخاصة لانهاء الحرب ضد
مواجهة جوية مباشرة بين واشنطن
وموسكو. وذلك عندما اعلنت الدفاع
اللاذعة للقيادة الروسية? ومن
ارض الى السماء حيث اندلعت هناك
الهجوم الاوكراني والمستشار
الالماني شولتس يرمي الطعم امام
يسعني الا ان اقول ان الهجوم
المضاد سيبدأ قريبا. ومع اقتراب
السلطات السوفيتية في موسكو هي
التي شكلت دولة سمتها اوكرانية
فلاديمير بوتين ليذكر بان
اوكرانيا لم تكن موجودة على وان
المتطرفة الاوكرانية التي كانت
قد توغلت في مقاطعة بيلجرون.
الاوروبي فور استعادتها اراضيها.
ومن الحرب الباردة بين الغرب
تتورط اكثر فاكثر في النزاع. فهل
**** الغرب في الوحل الروسي
في وجه اوكرانيا. عندما وضع
الغرب ثقله العسكري في الميزان
يعيد بوتين هولندا من الفعل
الحاضر الى الماضي لنقل كان هناك
النيران الالمانية واليوم يختلف
الزمان والسلاح وبضغطة زر قد
يابانية مصرحا لدينا بالفعل الحد
الادنى الضروري من الاسلحة ولا
القتال. بينما كانت صحيفة
بوليتكو قد ذكرت نقلا عن مستشار
مهلا مهلا. ففي زمن هتلر كان
لهولندا النصيب الاكبر من
على خط روسيا الاحمر لتصبح في
مواجهة حتمية مع الدب الروسي.
يتاجرون بالحرب لملء ارصدتهم من
الدعم الغربي وفق الصحيفة. الامر
تريليون دولار. ليس ذلك فحسب حيث
ذكرت صحيفة بوليتكو انه منذ
بشأن سقف الدين الوطني. وذلك بعد
ان وصل حجم دين واشنطن الى الحد
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يوري ساك
ان هولندا قد تصبح اول دولة تنقل
الاوكرانيين. وذلك باعلانه ان
اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في الاتحاد
الوزراء الباكستاني عمران خان
بكفالة على ذمة محاكمته في ثماني
بيان الوزارة الروسية. الاحداث
والتطور هنا هدوء حذر في
الروسية ان مقاتلة من طراز سو
سبعة وعشرين اعترضت قاذفتين
المعارك اصلا. فهل يصمت بوتين
طويلا امام تصريحات بريجوجن
اوسمة الشجاعة التي سيقلدها
الرئيس الروسي لمقاتلي فاغنر لا
الدفاع الروسية. ليعتبر طباخ
بوتين مؤسس مجموعة فاجنر ان
هناك سيعمق الخلاف الذي تفجر
سابقا بين مجموعة فاغنر ووزارة
الام وذلك وفق تعبير بوتين. وفي
باخموت يبدو ان النصر الروسي
الدفاع الروسية ان قواتها تمكنت
من القضاء على الفصائل القومية
على اراضي الامبراطورية الروسية.
ليضيف بوتين بان روسيا لم تبدأ
وعلى عكس مجرى الاحداث اعلن
كيريل بودانوف رئيس الاستخبارات
انتهاكها. اعلنت القوات البحرية
الدولية المشتركة بقيادة
بيسكوف قائلا ان الدول الغربية
التي تزود اوكرانيا بالاسلحة
ثمن الفاتورة ليعلنها المتحدث
باسم الرئاسة الروسية ديمتري
الاوروبي طلبت من قيادة الاتحاد
تعويضات ما بقيمة عشرة مليارات
بداية العملية الروسية بدأ
السياسيون الاوكرانيون بقيادة
الاقصى المحدد وهو واحد وثلاثون
فاصل ثلاثمائة وواحد وثمانون
قضايا تتعلق بالعنف واثارة
الاضطرابات. ضخ الاسلحة الغربية
قررت محكمة مكافحة الارهاب في
اسلام اباد الافراج عن رئيس
هذا قد يدفع اسرائيل لشن عمل
عسكري. واكد رئيس الاركان
العسكري فالحرب الاوكرانية محكوم
عليها بالفشل لانها معركة
العقوبات الاوروبية على روسيا
امر يتعارض مع الفترة السليمة.
لتعزيز الامن البحري في الشرق
الاوسط. قال رئيس اركان ان ايران
ليعود بيسكوف ويؤكد بان ضخ
الاسلحة الغربية الى كييف بما في
هولندا. فهل ينفد صبر الدب
الروسي ليضغط على الزر سهوا لكن
على الغرب. ليصرح هذه المرة بان
فكرة فرض الحزن الحادية عشر من
طائرة مقاتلة من طراز اف ستة عشر
الى كييب. وبذلك ستدوس هولندا
ذلك طائرات عشر لا يمكنه بتاتا
تغيير الوضع بشكل اساسي في ساحات
فرصة للانتصار لم يرسل الناتو
قواته الى ارض المعركة اي ان
تتأرجح اكثر فاكثر. ليعلنها رئيس
الوزراء ان اوكرانيا لا تمتلك
يورو كتعويض عن توريد الاسلحة
الى اوكرانيا فكيف ستدفع كييف
البلاد اي ان مسئولي الحكومة
الاوكرانية بقيادة الزينونسكي
اجل غير مسماة بسبب المناقشات
المستمرة في الولايات المتحدة
ان التمويل العسكري الامريكي
لاوكرانيا قد يتوقف مؤقتا الى
القصة؟ بينما اعلن الروس عن
مواجهة عسكرية جوية ضد
وجنوده. وهناك وجه اوربان بوصلته
نحو واشنطن قائلا لا نريد ان
شديد اللهجة للسودان وعمران خان
حر تليق مرة اخرى. اوروبا تعلنها
الالماني يعلن موعد انضمام
اوكرانيا للاتحاد الاوروبي ان
والولايات المتحدة تدير ظهرها
تاركة اليد الاوكراني. والمستشار
بعد ان افرغ مخازنه للاوكرانيين?
مضيفا ان المناقشات بهذا الشأن
مستمر. ما الذي يجري في بروكسل?
تعلمنا الولايات المتحدة كيفية
العيش. لم يتوقف عن اطلاق سهامه
اوربان يعترف بخسارة اوكرانيا ما
لم يتدخل الناتو بعدته وعتاده
الاوكراني ظلت كفة الروس ثابتة
لا تميل. والكفة الاوكرانية
طباخ بوتين يرفض هدية بوتين
الرئاسية. فما هو السبب هي
الامريكان. والاوروبيون يطالبون
كييف بتسديد ثمن الفاتورة
بريجوجن تصارح اوكرانيا بهذه
الكارثة العسكرية. وتهديد امريكي
لوجيستية كما قال. وهنا تنضم
الولايات المتحدة الى قافلة
يزداد سوءا على الاوكران. وهنا
عادا بوريل يقول ان دول الاتحاد
لا يمنع قوات موسكو من التقدم.
برأيكم ما الذي استفاده الغرب
الاسرائيلي ان بلاده لديها
القدرة على ضرب ايران واذرعها.
احرزت تقدما في تخصيب اليورانيوم
اكثر من اي وقت مضى مشيرا الى ان
الرئيسكي اعادة توزيع غير
قانونية للاعمال التجارية في
خرقت الهدنة في السودان فلن يخفى
ذلك عنهم وسيحاسب المسؤولون عن
الولايات المتحدة عن انشاء فرقة
عمل جديدة الفرق واربعة وخمسين
الافلاس العسكري في مخازن
الذخيرة والاسلحة. لتعلن صحيفة
البلطيق. حيث نجحت في منعهما من
انتهاك الاجواء الروسية بحسب
العسكرية الاوكرانية في حديث
لقناة ان اتش كي التليفزيونية
الخرطوم. وذلك مع سريان الهدنة
بين الجيش والدعم السريع رغم
حاجة لها اذا كان الكريملين
سيقلد مثلها من لم يشارك في
لها بالاحداث في منطقة بلجرود
الروسية. وهنا عاد الرئيس الروسي
مؤكدة مقتل اكثر من سبعين مسلحا
ماكييف من جهتها فنفت اي علاقة
الاجابة تأتي من الناتو. حيث قال
الامين العام للحلف انستوتنبرج
ان حرب اوكرانيا قد استنزفتهم
وان لم يرفع الحلف انتاجه
ولماذا فشل الاتحاد بالاجماع على
العقوبات يا له من امر غريب.
الخارجية في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل فشل وزراء الدفاع
وروسيا نعود الى الحرب
الاوكراني. حيث اعلنت وزارة
الاوروبيين بالاتفاق على حزمة
مساعدات عسكرية جديدة لاوكرانيا.
لتصل الرسالة الهونجارية الى
الاوروبيين حيث اعلن مفوض سياسة
استراتيجيتين امريكيتين من طراز
بي وان بي كانتا تحلقان فوق بحر
الحرب لكننا سننهيها. وهولندا
تتجه لتصبح عدو روسيا الاول. فما